la solidarité au débit c'est vrai que ça
a été assez compliqué parce que ducos
effectivement s'est battu mais on est
très solidaire donc jusqu'au bon c'est
battre pour toi et vous obtenez quand
même un peu la vie dure oui au début ça
a été très compliqué oui maguette on n'a
pas lâché
c'était jusqu'au bout on avait envie de
gagner on a gagné sans vous pour vous
cette province et beaucoup beaucoup de
choses on monte en pré nat
ça nous permet de m'entraîner pour nous
c'est énormément énormément restera dix
est faible et où vous attendiez ce titre
que le sporting n'est pas m'apporter une
coupe comme si on avait déjà remporté
on n'est pas descendu mais là on remonte
pas les plus forts qu est ce qu avait
bloqué pêcher la dernière fois qu'on
faisait monter sur mon pinceau bain
malheureusement on n'était pas assez
solidaires mais bon c'est plus au match
retour on s'est battu jusqu'au bout
mais là cette fois ça va être chaud
reggio préfère la saison bnf
oui on a placé on va se battre jusqu'au
bout quelles que soient les résultats
on va se battre jusqu'au bout